trying forward purposefully
not the way to try and get them
[Music]
Adam Mason hello we've been playing lots
of FIFA and lots of pears I know you
lean slightly more towards the FIFA size
than I yeah although I think we both
sort of appreciate the merits of each
game yeah well what is it about FIFA
that makes you on the pitch specifically
yeah what is it about FIFA I don't know
I think like overall gameplay wise FIFA
for me just feels more smoother and
natural make me that's purely historical
I think like because I've been playing
FIFA for seven eight years and its
current iteration before that I actually
was much more into Pez
so I kind of had that switch so I think
it FIFA just feels more natural to me
and I think this year in particular it's
been smoothed out a lot of those rough
edges from c418 have been smoothed out
they've definitely I think there's been
lots of little quality of life
improvements it's probably how a
marketing person will put this yeah
definitely I think yeah like it's a lot
of small differences but like if you're
looking at it from like a big picture
sort of view I think it just feels more
dynamic it feels a bit more responsive
it feels sort of smooth in terms of like
you know player movement but like when
you're looking at the smaller details
like there's lots of really nice sort of
tweaks that I think like you say quality
of life stuff like the ability to where
the camera doesn't move when you're
having a goal kick there's stuff like
the in the mini-map there's triangles
now to differentiate yeah and like and
there's a second player marker as well
there's like which all sound like really
tiny details but over the course of a
year they add up definitely and the
cumulative effect of those is huge yeah
but like I said what about PES then like
where do you feel PES is kind of taken
those little steps or is it taking
bigger steps I don't I don't think
either game has taken huge steps on the
pitch has a strength specifically when
compared to FIFA is how good the ball
feels yeah and like it's kind of weirdly
an often-overlooked part of a football
game is
feels yeah the ball in pairs I think
feels a lot wait here right it was like
it's got like a life of its own where is
in FIFA it's so it's almost prescribed
as in pairs it's got that
unpredictability it feels to me I find
it far more satisfying when I'm actually
on the pitch to play PES than FIFA I
think FIFA is made I think you're right
FIFA has made strides on the pitch not
huge ones but it does feel more
responsive and I think the passing
through passing in particular is
actually useful now whereas for the past
two years lob through balls have been
useless yeah and I think pace is
probably in a good place now because for
years they bear it
they went from pace being massively over
power to massively underpowered
depending on what's actually liked in
pairs I think paces are really in that
they've really done something
interesting with it this year where it's
not like I mean in FIFA and in previous
players I've always been just holding
pace where I'm doing anything yeah yeah
now in pairs it feels like you need to
be using a smart but a bit more smarter
you know you got a definitely to succeed
in PES you have to play as you would in
real life you have to be very very
patient that's the main difference for
me is that I think FIFA is probably a
lot easier to get into and I think
there's a lot more accessible when it
comes to stuff like the two button
options and it's generally I think an
easier game to sort of get the hang of
in general PES is a lot more sort of
specific but I think if you're someone
who really wants to delve deep into a
football game or soccer game over the
next 12 months I think you will probably
get more enjoyment out of the on pitch
stuff specifically from person licensing
seems like a bit of an unfair fight
really yeah it's not quite a perfect
match up is it no lifer definitely has
more licenses and he has the bigger
licenses when it comes to stuff like the
Premier League and La Liga
well I obviously the big one we've gotta
talk about is champions new Europa
League staff yeah which traditionally
has been with PES for a long time and
FIFA's just come in and sniped it yeah
yeah I mean in fairness I think I think
EA have done a really good job with the
Champions League stuff it does look
really really nice and I think they've
you know they've gone all light on it as
you would expect and there's its own
mode and it's in career mode and there's
gonna be Champions League specific stuff
in Ultimate Team they do a really good
job of it and when you do get into a
match and it is a Champions League night
it does feel good and yeah PES obviously
has a trickier road here in Konami
budget I would imagine probably isn't as
high as EAS so they don't have the same
level of trick lei licenses they have
some like Arsenal is in there and a fish
in an official capacity yeah or
Barcelona and I think they've got the
Russian Premier League in and
exclusively and the Scottish Premier
yeah well I think that's what they
they've taken a I think more of a laser
focused approach with their licensing
this year right so like you got leagues
that are specifically geared towards
their their core markets right yeah so
it looks like you know turkey Russia
there's a lot at the South America oh
yeah Scotland I think like what they're
doing is they're finding those leagues
in the territories where PES is a big
you know game that's where we play a lot
of pairs I think that's quite smart
today I think it is a smart move yeah
and I think you're right I think they
would also love to have the Premier
League in a league abut those licenses
are at the moment
out of their hands and to EA and I think
there's will be improved by having those
licenses but the good thing is that
there's a huge community of Pro Evo
players I
essentially allow you to mod all of
these licenses in for free economies
credit they do make it as easy as
possible every year it gets easier and
easier to mob that stuff in there very
clearly opening the door to the
community they clearly can't like
signposted or saying here add your
hostesses exactly but like they're very
clearly leaving the door ajar yeah and I
think they do all they can really
annoyingly that isn't available for Xbox
players only on place though it's only
ps4 one piece all pieces are although EA
clearly does win this round hands down
yeah I think like if you would just
recommend like a game that looks and
feels like football is FIFA right yeah
the Champions League Victor's for 2019
[Applause]
so final topic Adam is modes tell us
what is the big new thing in FIFA this
year in terms of its mode availability
so FIFA I think the big new thing this
year is the sort of range of crazy modes
that you can get in kick-off now like
chief among them you've got like the
house rules modes which we've been
playing a lot of in our lunch breaks
so there's survival mode which
everyone's heard a lot about which is
the battle really for me yeah which is
actually a really fun mode you know I
every time someone scores they lose a
player it kind of really switches the
dynamics of the game
I'm sure you've got the hang of it now
that's a goal and a player removed and
maybe more room for the other team my
personal favorite is the no rules mode
and that's because I'm a date you are
stood on the page and it's just a lot of
fun but it just makes for a really crazy
game of feed focus like there is like no
literally you can foul everyone and
everyone else I know aside your strategy
turn from when you slide tackled or
tackled you're you stopped aiming at the
ball and started aiming at the player
exactly yeah that's the shot that I play
at there deny it's like the ball will go
spinning yeah yeah it's a lot of fun
it's it like completely changes what it
means to play football
really and like although they're in
essence they are quite shallow modes
like I already I've already sort of
found myself getting a little bit bored
with the no rules
yeah only played maybe three or four
matches with it but it's I think it's
good to like it's fun to when you're
playing locally like we do a lot of
people do it's fun to like jump around
between modes because you can play a
normal game then you can go straight to
the Chams League final which is also a
new thing and then you can go play no
rules or survival or headers and Wally's
I think it's a really nice sense of
variety the downside to all of this
though Adam is that kickoff can't be
played online it's local area or that
the new choir is which is really dumb
and career mode which is what I
generally play most has not been changed
at all yeah other than having a
Champions League in it pro clubs hasn't
changed at all ultimate team has a new
mode that's called division rivals
that's basically the same as an old
there's no longer there any yeah yeah
it's looking a bit desperate
other than kickoff yeah when it comes to
pairs I think where you've got my club
which has been sort of they're calling
it its biggest overhaul ever it's it's
still not really as Ultimate Team Master
League is similar to career mode and
FIFA it's not being touched
PES has probably fallen a little bit
behind this year after making quite a
lot of grind up last year with random
selection mode which is thankfully still
there and that has that changed much it
hasn't changed at all right so it's
basically it is a great mode though it's
fantastic
and I think the new kickoff in FIFA with
all those House Rules modes I think that
to me is sort of a direct reaction to
random selection year in pairs because
random selection is so good and for
anyone who doesn't know it's basically
you get given a random selection of
players but then you get the opportunity
to steal players before the match off of
your friend yeah when it comes to modes
as a whole I think FIFA definitely has
the edge but there's still work to do
from EA like career mode and pro clubs
have just massively stagnated over the
past couple of years and they're
desperately in need of some attention
and and for PES players random selection
and mass illegal looking and my club are
looking like you go to once again so
FIFA probably does have the edge on this
one yeah so overall then Adam who would
you recommend FIFA to would you even
recommend FIFA at all yeah I think this
year's FIFA is is like a great addition
to that you know long-running series
like I think there's enough new modes
and content in there especially with
like the kick off modes and the journey
that it's got significant sort of
enhancements their gameplay wise I think
it is a smoother experience maybe not
quiet the same level as PES yet but like
better than last year for sure
yeah I think when it comes to PES is
definitely an improvement over last year
I think if you're a football purist and
and you have you want that attention to
detail that the community will give you
yeah and you want to have that amazing
feeling when when you do an amazing
slick passing move I think PES is your
game
I think FIFA is great at what it does
and it and it
has probably better authenticity and it
does better stuff with the licenses than
PES but they've both got their their
pros and I think they're both worthy
additions to their own series
[Applause]
another page in the history all right
guys thank you very much for watching
let us know what you think of FIFA in
PES this year in the comments below or
you can come and yell at us on Twitter
I'm at they said I'm at Adam riess Mase
we've got new episodes vs. every
Thursday on GameSpot so check it out and
we'll see you next time
[Music]